Cinthia Roden are there seemingly basic
life skills that many people lack okay
I don't anytime we get these questions I
worry that I'm going to offend people
and then someone writes in and says
David don't worry about offending people
just give us your opinion so that's
exactly what I'm going to do the ability
to communicate effectively in written
form okay this is a basic life skill
that way too many people lack I
communicate with people who have not
insignificant jobs and roles that they
are involved in that require writing and
they are writing like they are in fourth
or fifth grade right and I find it very
very off-putting because it generally
makes me question if their writing is
like this what's their thinking like
have you experienced that Pat without
naming anybody but even like in guest
booking for the show that some people
can't communicate well in written form
right or so sometimes I'll offer two
dates for an interview to them and
they'll respond by saying yes so then
you have to follow up like which one
then that's not really an answer to this
question yeah I think that's a skill
that is lacking number two basic
financial skills just very simple
financial skills the time value of money
right the the the concept of how the
time value of money has to be adjusted
whether you're thinking about money
available in the future or now interest
rates etc the basics of debt right I
mean just basic personal finance and
understanding credit and debt and how to
make a budget I know so many people who
I know are not doing well financially
and they seem to have incredibly lacks
control over just charging fifty bucks
in a few drinks at an offensive bar or
whatever and I it just those basic
financial skills are significantly
lacking and I don't know Pat since
you're younger do you see I think the
financial skills hopefully will come
with age although it doesn't always
happen that way in the United States do
you see friends of yours who just seem
to spend uncontrollably oh maybe so
because you know you got out of college
where you may have been making some
minimum-wage salary and then you get you
know something that you're qualified for
and you're gonna be
obviously making a lot of money but then
you don't realize that you now have
expenditures to like friend and student
loans and all of that so I definitely
have seen that as well
basic critical thinking skills too many
people lack the ability to critically
analyze messages that they're given and
I know that this relates specifically to
what I'm teaching at Boston College and
have been lecturing on but basic
critical thinking skills can you
identify when you are being given a
conclusion that doesn't follow from the
premises and you are being led astray
and that relates to media literacy as
well I I don't you know my instinct is
that the problem is partially that those
skills aren't being taught early in
school
certainly not in elementary school I
don't really think in middle school or
high school at least in many parts of
the country but I meet so many people
and maybe maybe because we work in media
Pat we notice it even more but I'll bump
into someone who casually will say hey
did you see what's going on with X or Y
I saw a news story about it and it's
immediately obvious that they have no
clue what the story is about they might
have heard a headline and didn't go any
further than further than that or they
heard one news story and are completely
unable to critically analyze it and this
leads to people like Trump getting
elected sadly yeah and it's not even
worth it to bring it up in the first
place if you haven't looked at the
source and read the article I completely
agree with you there I'm thinking about
just basic cleaning skills like I've
lived with people in an apartment and
you know sometimes they would have a
tray of food and go a few hours without
attempting to clean it and then
obviously the food will stick to the
plate a little bit and they just try to
throw it into the dishwasher thinking
that will magically wash the dish you
got to do a little bit more than that
you've got to soak those plates right I
mean what what what you you you think
that things are just gonna be clean if
you toss them in the dishwasher no doubt
and I think with that one just general
lack of knowledge about you know you do
want to change your sheets with some
regularity and usually you want to wash
those in warm water and it's a pretty
good idea to you you know sweep and mop
the floors and the bathrooms every once
in a while I know a lot of people who
still even in their 30s don't really
ever clean their apartments which is it
strikes me as odd it doesn't
I think they just start to get used to
it but if you're having guests over
frequently that reason alone should be
enough for you to clean your habitat
what uh what I would give for a camera
in Pat's place when he's hosting a
cocktail party that would be that would
be an experience
maybe the videos available online who
knows maybe it already is out there